nun aber zur Überraschung der Woche laut
Bertelsmann Stiftung hat die Ampel zur
Halbzeit 38% ihrer versprechen ganz oder
teilweise umgesetzt das ist wirklich
kein schlechter Wert und das heißt diese
Regierung ist wohl besser als ihr Ruf
fakt ist allerdings auch der ein oder
andere Ampel Star
strahlt nicht mehr so richtig Nancy
Phaser zum Beispiel SPD
Spitzenkandidatin in Hessen die aber nur
in ihr Heimatland zurückwählen nach der
Hessenwahl wenn sie auch gewinnt ne ja
gut das ist keine tolle Idee denn man
wir wissen doch seit Norbert Röntgen
damals das sowas safe in die Hose geht
immer da ist sie beratungsresistent sie
könnte doch nach einer Niederlage auch
Oppositionsführerin werden ich möchte
von vornherein sagen dass ich nicht als
Oppositionsführerin zurück nach Hessen
komme das war ich nämlich schon
ach so ja dann kann man wohl nichts
machen ne ich dachte zwar bei so einer
Hessenwahl geht's irgendwie um Hessen
und nicht um Abwechslung im Lebenslauf
aber
muss man respektieren hier unnötig
ehrlicherweise spot
ist Nancy 100% Hessin die liebt Hessen
jetzt bewerbe ich mich darum
Ministerpräsidentin von Hessen zu werden
aus vollem Herzen gut sagen wir aus
halben Herzen oder Viertel denn mal
ehrlich Hessen ist ganz okay aber hast
du mal die Clubszene in Berlin gesehen
Alter und dann dagegen Essen klar kannst
du dir mal einen Tag angucken aber da
leben da muss man doch sagen nein nein
eben Hessen manche Leute müssen da
wohnen die nicht
wenn sie gewinnt würden sie ja daneben
wenn sie gewinnt also kurz gesagt falls
irgendwer unter den Zuschauern eine
Wohnung in Wiesbaden zu vermieten hat
nennt sie Feser braucht die
wahrscheinlich nicht ja so und dann ist
sie natürlich auch noch
bundesinnenministerin was aber ebenfalls
nur so mittel läuft der ehemalige Chef
des Bundesamtes für Sicherheit in der
Informationstechnik Arne Schönborn klagt
wegen seiner Versetzung wissen Sie
bestimmt zur Erinnerung das ZDF Magazin
Royal hatte schönbum unter anderem
Kontakte zu einem Verein mit zu viel
Russland Nähe vorgeworfen ja also plus
eine gewisse Inkompetenz in cyberfragen
die Redaktion steht bis heute zu ihrer
Kritik aber meine ganz andere Frage
warum erwecke ich als Ministerin ohne
Noten Eindruck ich würde wichtige Leute
wegen einer Satire Sendung versetzen man
hätte doch vor dem öffentlichen
Vertrauensentzug alles in Ruhe prüfen
können
warum die Hektik und wenn es tatsächlich
Zweifel ein schönbums Eignung für den
cyber-job gab warum hat man ihn dann
noch so lange im Amt gelassen
in diesem Bundestagswahlkampf wie sehr
ist in Deutschland gefährdet das werden
wir am Ende sehen wenn der
Bundestagswahlkampf zu Ende ist
aha korrekt wäre natürlich gewesen Teile
der Antwort könnten die Bevölkerung
verunsichern
könnte es eventuell sein dass die
Ministerin ihn schon länger loswerden
wollte und nur auf einen Anlass gewartet
hat also als Hypothese einfach mal in
den Raum gestellt
unmöglicherweise haben wir das ganze
Thema cybersicherheit als Land insgesamt
viel zu lange unterschätzt immer noch
einen Tag vor Putins Überfall auf die
Ukraine sah das Bundesamt für Sicherheit
in der Informationstechnik ja so aus
weil wir gedacht haben wer soll uns
Deutsche schon angreifen aus den Tiefen
des Netzes wir haben uns zu sicher
gefühlt alle Mann inzwischen hat sich
das zum Glück verbessert wegen der
ständigen Hackerangriffe aus Russland
und China musste das BSE
selbstverständlich reagieren und hat
jetzt viel mehr Mitarbeiter angestellt
mit tollen Laptops hier da merkt der
neue Abteilungsleiter dass die Firewall
nicht richtig funktioniert ja
wir lernen eben alle dazu ja wir alle
auch Nancy fazer die nächste Woche doch
mal im Innenausschuss des Bundestages
erscheinen und kritische Fragen
beantworten will nach zweimal Schwänzen
mit absurden Ausreden nächsten Mittwoch
wird endlich für Transparenz gesorgt
da kommst du dann aber auch wirklich
oder
sehr gerne
wie schön und natürlich liegt es nicht
nur an Frau fäser dass die SPD in
aktuellen Umfragen im Bund gerade bei 17
Prozent rumdümpelt so was ist ja immer
eine Gemeinschaftsproduktion ist ja auch
logisch meine zumindest in der
öffentlichen Wahrnehmung setzt die SPD
zu wenig Akzente in der Ampel
73% der Deutschen halten Olaf Scholz für
Durchsetzung schwach 73 Prozent ist das
unfair ich leite das mal weiter denn
till reiner schreibt aktuell die
Biografie des Kanzlers und begleitet ihn
dafür rund um die Uhr er hat sogar einen
eigenen Schreibtisch im Kanzler bürotel
das ist ja unglaublich so nah dran sein
was kriegt man da alles mit ja nix und
ich hatte mich so gefreut hautnah dabei
sein wenn Olaf Scholz bist tief in die
Nacht verhandelt wir mit anderen
streitet das ganze Land mit Reis mit
seinen Argumenten macht er aber nie ab
und zu Freude die Putzfrau immer die
Spinnweben weg oder der Arbeit kommt in
die Zimmerpflanze nach zwei Jahren weiß
ich nichts über Olaf Scholz hier diese
Kollegin war die einzige die überhaupt
mal was rausfinden konnte über ihn was
ist ihre lieblingseissorte
so eine Tüte wo ich dann ein
Schokoladeneis und ein Zitroneneis drin
habe
ja das ist der einzige Satz den ich nach
zwei Jahren Arbeit hier stehen habe Olaf
Scholz mag Schokolade und Zitrone toll
das reicht doch nicht für ein Buch als
würde ich ein Hörspiel machen über ein
schwarzes Loch Pantomime im Radio
FDP und Grüne streiten immer weiter
aktuell über Industriestrom und der
Kanzler lässt sich alles laufen hier die
Scholz Highlights sehen aus der großen
ARD-Doku vom Montag von hinten Scholz
steht an einem Fenster und blickt auf
grüne Baumkronen
dann sitzt er auf einem Fenster Sims und
Start vor sich hin
Gänsehaut okay das war der Kommentar für
blinde und sehbehinderte Menschen aber
trotzdem treffend seine Regierung hofft
sich und er gibt immer nur den Papa der
wartet bis die Kinder sich müde getobt
haben diese Kinder werden aber nicht
müde die haben ADHS die AFD liegt in den
Umfragen vor der Kanzlerpartei SPD und
alles was im Kanzler dazu einfällt ist
das ist eine schlechte Laune Partei also
das wirksamste gegen Rechtsextreme sind
Witze ja dann lass mal einen hören
kennst du einen Olaf Scholz Witz
findest du einen so witzig dass du uns
erzählen willst
ich habe so Gedächtnislücken
ja wie schön dass Du schon wieder lachen
kann übrigens lauten Steuern Millionen
das sind die Hauptsache absolut bitter
zwei Jahre schreiben und das spannendste
war die olle Augenklappe mit Blick auf
die Umfragen müssen scheut sich fragen
brauche ich eigentlich beide Beine mit
Holzbein wäre doch noch besser komm egal
mein Geld verdiene ich jetzt eh anders
und zwar als Ghostwriter von Christian
Lindner hier schon fertig der Schmücker
alle Gesetze bei denen sich die FDP
durchgesetzt hat indem wir den
Koalitionspartnern so lange auf den Sack
gegangen sind bis sie gesagt haben ja
gut dann mach Zeit 5000 Seiten
knisternde Spannung und das ist erst
teil 1 um Gottes vielen Dank
wir haben gesagt die soll man ihn
Lieblingswitz erzählen was mache ich
gerne also kommen ein Pferd Jeff Bezos
und der Papst in eine Bar sagt der
Barkeeper aboniert endlich den
verkackten heute schon
keine Ahnung also geht doch